from you looking at this
layout of what's been happening in
cryptocurrency
uh the evolution of this technology
how has it
rolled out
differently than you could have imagined
in two ways one the technology itself
and two
the human side of things the human
stories of the hackers
and
the financial folks and the powerful and
the powerless
the human side of things yeah well
cryptonomicon is pre
bitcoin it's pre-satoshi it's
pre-blockchain as you point out
so
um
at that point uh i was kind of reacting
to
what i was seeing among
people like the bay area cypherpunks in
berkeley there was some sunriser branch
here in austin as well
and a lot of their
thinking was
so based on the idea that you would have
to have
a physical uh region of the earth that
was free of government
interference
you couldn't achieve that freedom
by purely mathematical
means on the network you actually had to
have you know a room somewhere with
servers in it
that uh that a government couldn't come
and meddle with
and so a lot of ideation happened around
that view of things that
there were efforts to figure out
jurisdictions where this might work
there was a lot of interest for a while
in anguilla which is a caribbean island
that had some unusual jurisdictional
properties
there was sea land sea land which is a
platform in the north sea
and so there was a lot of effort that
went into finding these physical
locations that that were deemed kind of
safe
and that all
goes away
with
blockchain
it's no longer necessary
and so that really changes the picture
in a lot of ways because
[Music]
you no longer have
i mean from a novelist point of view the
old system was a lot more fun to work
with because it gives you a situation
where hackers
are wandering around in strange parts of
the world you know trying to set up
server rooms so that's a great
storytelling
thing
there's still a little bit of that right
in in the modern world but it's just
there's several server rooms as opposed
to one centralized one yeah yeah and
there's the like the new wrinkle is the
need to do a lot of computation
and to keep your your uh
your your gpus from melting down so
people building things in iceland or or
in shipping containers on the bottom of
the ocean or whatever
um
so um but there's still governments
involved and there's they're still from
a novelist perspective interesting
dynamics
what is big governments like uh china
and and more sort of renegade
governments from all over the world
trying to contend with this idea
of what to do uh in terms of control and
power over these kinds of
centers that do the mining of the yeah
of the cryptocurrency
yeah so we're in a stage now that kind
of goes beyond the initial
like there's the stuff i was describing
in
kryptonomicon had a little bit of air
about it of the underpants gnomes
in that you know we're gonna we're gonna
build this system
and then
we'll make money somehow uh but the the
intermediate step was was left out
um
and that is uh
uh i i think we're now
so
into that phase of the thing where the
where bitcoin you know blockchain exists
people know how it works
uh bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
exist people are using them and sort of
like okay what now you know where does
this all lead
um
so um do you have a sense of where it
all leads like is it is it possible that
the set of technology kind of
continues to have
uh transformational effects on
not just sort of
finance but
who gets to have power in this world
so the decentralization of power
you know big questions right so i guess
there's a little bit of the cynic in me
thinking that
as soon as it becomes important enough
the existing banks and people in power
are gonna sort of control it i guess an
easy answer is that maybe it won't be a
big change in the end um
there's a utopian strain sometimes in in
the way people think about this that
i'm not so sure about
there there's a there is a technological
aspect to
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
that make it a little easier
to uh pull along the utopian thread yeah
because it's harder for governments to
control
bitcoin yeah i mean they they have much
fewer options
the they can ban they can make it
illegal it's it's more difficult yeah so
technology here is on the side of the
powerless the voiceless which is a very
interesting
idea of course yes it does have a
utopian
feel to it but we have been making
progress throughout human history yeah
maybe this is what progress looks like
there will be
the powerful and the greedy
and the bureaucrats that take advantage
of it skim off the top kind of thing
but maybe this does give um more power
to people that haven't had power before
in a good way like distributing power
and enabling sort of more um
greater resistance to sort of uh
dictatorships and authoritarian regimes
that kind of thing
and also enabling all kinds of
technologies built built on top of it
ultimately when you
digitize money
uh you know money is a kind of speech or
it's it's kind of like um
mechanism of
how humans interact
and if you make that digital more and
more of the world moves to the digital
space
and then you can have
the
then you can finally fully live in that
virtual reality with the toaster and
then
yeah
yeah in a lot of ways i think in that
realm of technology that the money per
se is one of the less interesting things
you can do with it so i think you know
cryptographically enforceable contracts
and
organizations built on those
that seems to me like it's got more
potential for change just because we do
already have
money
and although it's an old system
um it's been digitized to a large extent
by
you know the the stripes and the credit
card companies of the world
and i also love the idea of like uh
connecting so to connecting two smart
contracts connecting data
sort of
uh
making it more formal it's like
mathematica
more structured the integration of data
of
weather data
of uh
all kinds of data about the the
the stuff in the world so they can make
contracts between people that in that's
grounded in data and that's actually
getting closer to
something like truth
because then you can make agreements
based on actual data versus kind of
perceptions of data and if you can
formalize
like distribute the power of who gets to
tell the story yeah
that that's an interesting kind of um
resistance yeah again the
powerful in the space of narrative yeah
david brin has been saying for a while
that um
the only way to settle arguments with
you know across the political divide is
to to make bets
so people can say
you know
the election was stolen or you know what
whatever controversial position they're
they're taking
um
and they'll keep saying it until you
you uh
you wager real money on it
um
so um
so maybe there's something there
if you could
kind of turn that into a
put a user interface on that thing you
know
you